hello we're reaching exciting finale
here in st. Louis at the 2012 us chess
championship I'm Jennifer's hottie and
this is my climb in our championship
section we have two players completely
outpacing everyone Rama Sri Hikaru
Nakamura also world number seven and
defending champion gata kamsky a point
and a half ahead of the rest of the
field that's right Jennifer you know in
today in round 8 gotta calm skis next
victim was the young GM Alex Len derman
when Lenormand came down for the
postgame commentary he basically
admitted that short of his good opening
preparation he had a lot to learn about
chess but somehow it was just I just
started missing details and I just I
don't know the game just got away from
me I just think I can't explain it
indeed in chemistry gave a real clinic
in positional chess playing Bishop takes
s3e 5qg 6 h 5 just totally dominating
and the best part was when he started
giving his comments in the Nakamura game
a lot of the other grandmasters thought
that maybe stripping ski was on top and
gotta got a lot of chuckles when he said
that that's not how he understands jazz
well it looks it looks likely that um
you're gonna leap into the clear of eat
with this round okay you don't think so
you think your car is gonna win that
game sure we were thinking Bishop h2g
for Bishop back to g3 than English for
don't like that for him that is uh
that's a very different chest from what
I'm playing
that's right it turns out gotta knows
best he was suggesting a plan involving
the f pawn moving after the f pong got
to f4 strip Linsky realized that he
didn't want to wait for the inevitable
and started pitching pieces at hikaru
first it was a bishop then he sacked the
exchange and finally at the end of the
game he sacrificed his final piece his
rook for another exchange trying to get
as many past bones as he could in the
end his five passed pawns though were no
match for a carros rook who hung out on
the back rank and just waited for those
cons of advance that he can mowed them
down mr. Polinsky had to resign one of
many thrilling games here in the US
Championship another amazing roller
coaster game was Ramirez verse hi Donna
Ramirez seem to be playing brilliantly
but then [ __ ] I've defended so
creatively Ramirez looked ready to take
that work on a age but kind of played
this fantastic defense work to da now if
Ramirez took the rough Qaeda Nava would
come down with Queen III check followed
by Queen g3 work gt1 would fail to clean
takes h4 mate so it looked like Ramirez
was going to go down but then the game
took another turn when kinda blundered
with King day for leading to a long
combination in which Ramirez was able to
play a 8 equals Queen if kind of not
captured with his rook Bishop f3 check
and a score that's right Jen is a
paradoxical idea because Alejandro had
to pin his bishop only to release the
pin on the next move and one could
understand why card on tops could miss
something like that interestingly
Ramirez said that the tactic remind him
of a book Alexander coat off think like
a grandmaster which he studied when he
was nine years old there was a position
very similar to the tag to be played in
the game looking at the Women's
Championship the top two seeds played
today and what is becoming their annual
battle Ana's at on ski had white against
Irina Krush and after missing the
defensive idea night to d5 Anna really
could do nothing but simplify into a
dead equal endgame crush was able to
draw effortlessly and that was just fine
with her because looking ahead her next
two matches are much easier than
exactly Irina has to play again Elena
cats and behind sky key to the players
in this term who have been seriously
struggling whereas Ana's at on ski will
face Russia tango luciani and positive
Abrahamian two very formidable opponents
in fact we Russa Don is playing
fantastic chess I really liked her game
this round against top dev where she
played the nice clearance tactic f6 and
her queen age five Bishop f5 were key to
work too much for talk to me yeah rishta
called last year's championship the
worst tournament she's ever played in
and she said that she's had a little
more time to devote to the game this
year since her children are year older
and can take care of themselves a little
bit more and now she's just half a point
behind her main rivals Ana's at on ski
and Irina crash so the term it's only
going to get more exciting as we reach
the finale you're not going to want to
miss any of the action especially the
epic battle we have scheduled from round
10 between gotta kamsky and hikaru
nakamura join us live here in st. Louis
at one o'clock local time or you can
always catch all the action at two p.m.
eastern on us chest camps calm